now I believe that in fear had a little
bit of a different shooting experience
and motors you guys didn't meet until
you were on set I needed even know each
of you were part of it did you yeah I
know I I didn't meet Alan until he came
into a scene literally walked into a
scene and I made the great mistake of
asking after the take if he was a stunt
guy he has not forgiven me in fact your
performance in the film that you're
working that way and what did it answer
in fear because obviously were kind of
direct fed information as you went along
weren't you I think you know it was it
was really like nothing else I've done
in that um I think doing a genre piece
but with improvisation really added a
sort of we couldn't play the beats the
beats just came to us in a way like we
we're able to sort of approach the
stereotypes without feeling kind of
jaded or cynical and I love that I think
that's great yeah I think what it does
is it's a very organic process and way
of working and the reactions you see for
the first take of every every scene you
did we're exactly how you thought your
character would react because it was all
new information so it made it quite you
know see you to the pant's stuff and you
know a lot of the stuff like a lot of
the stone sister if we didn't even know
we're happening so it genuinely was
scary and we were in fear for her for
large periods of time appropriately
enough now the director jeremy has said
that he set out to maybe be an director
in this particular film like sam raimi
meets roman polanski at first he ended
up more like los von trier what did he
find him as a director and how scary was
the experience of filming in fear it was
it was actually terrifying but in the
clinic it was funny because it really
was like the experience of watching that
I think that you find watching the film
in
even when you know the beats are coming
it was still terrified you know we knew
something was going to happen in the
scene and she just I was it was like
being almost an audience member for to
the story and I was exhilarated I
trusted Jeremy completely I don't know
if that was a good like if I should but
like he really did I think illustrates
something kind of remarkable
yeah absolutely I mean I think we all
trust him he had this vision and this
idea of how to have to make the movie
and I think now haven't seen us yeah
well it's easy quite manipulative as a
person possibly would I what I trust him
with my Wallace no it's always good to
know who you can trust those it is yeah
yeah if it takes five weeks of filming
now you've both got very different
experiences coming up you with dance and
have got moving away from leaping out of
your skin and in theatres leaping in
time what's it be like changing that
time period for you guys it's been great
it's one of the great things about this
profession is you know one day you can
be caked in mud driving around in
Cornwall and the next you can be sitting
at a dinner table with Maggie's wigs
good hair it's it's been great and and
the series yes series four starts in
about three four weeks
and yeah it's very exciting to see
what's happening with those characters
as well what have you enjoyed most about
playing Tom so far I think his journey
has been his arc throughout the series
has been quite interesting and he's been
a bit of a victim of circumstance and
and for that I think I've enjoyed kind
of watching Tom grow and turn into this
character that is quite important in
that was now which is very far removed
from where he started you as much a
rebel as Thomas you think I wish no I'm
not I'm not as political as a Munich
palace you've got new worlds coming up
as well a new four-part channel 4 drama
tell us a little bit about that great
cast as well yeah no I you know just
actually came back from shooting this
week and it's just been brilliant I'm
loving it the cast is amazing and the I
I'm obsessed with that time period and
it's been written beautifully and I
don't really know how about say I think
I got in trouble yeah I don't know I
only have good things to say about it
finally you've got the invitation game
coming up with a little bit about that
yeah it's a better life of Alan Turing
and said of Bletchley Park and survived
the goings-on of the Enigma code and his
life and it's an amazing script Benedict
Cumberbatch's playing that so I'm really
excited about that I have a first
costume fitting the other day and yeah
it's gonna be it's gonna be amazing
are you excited to be making your first
Hollywood movie yeah well it's very much
a British movie I think and it's got an
incredible director and it's just very
exciting are you looking forward to
working with Benedict Cumberbatch yeah
yeah me I'm look that cast is incredible
such as this Benedict it's Keira
Knightley and it's it's a bit the paint
yourself cast so it's gonna be pretty
amazing
you